how do you guys I mean I saw where a
parent like it looked like there was a
ghost in the last episode you know it's
important to know that nothing in the
show is staged
none of it how do you know what lying to
the people about that it's nothing sure
say it isn't nothing or say no it's a
really interesting point though because
like what going into it yeah we were all
very we were going to be very careful
about the show because I mean it was
super important to us that our show
apart from shows what else it's our
family this is my representation we are
we're not going to do something we
didn't want to I like we had wanted it
wasn't like a classic reality thing they
refined yeah bringing in noises if we
wanted the authenticity and that's why
there are some weeks like we come back
and we say well that was a bust we
looked a little rattled right away well
I was yeah the one who doesn't really
you know forget you do a little rally I
say do some things were really hard to
explain but ya don't have to believe in
things to be scared of them I will stand
by that very true to catch you off guard
a little bit
you're uneasy you don't know what it is
totally it's been you know coming right
it might not be that the first episode
was a Throwdown yeah I mean it was it
was because there I guess said there's
some episodes where you just strike out
yeah I know still fun and there's also a
good time but this first episode just
happened to be one of the ones where we
could not believe it off strong like the
minute it got dark it got ugly Ricky how
was funny you guys have been doing this
mine almost it's like I mean you know it
is like if you've ever been camping
either by the campfire and your friends
are telling frightening stories and with
people you enjoy that's that's what we
that's what this was all about did you
feel like this could become a show I
mean I didn't like you're like hey let's
make a show we get to travel around and
check these things out and might not
just do when we heard when we heard it
we're like excuse me what's going on
which is by the way which is what's so
fun about it because it's such I've
never really seen a show like this
I mean it's so clearly inspired by shows
that I love but I've never seen anything
like this it's really really unique and
that we got an opportunity to do it it's
really special now provided this is true
provided there is ghosts out there
provided at the
it's conclusive who you guys want to
contact like is there is there somebody
is there a reason because I always feel
like sometimes you end up believing in
ghosts or an afterlife because there's
something you inherently want to believe
course yeah of course
so that's a big part of it yeah I mean
and the other part of it is you will see
things as we did in your logical brain
but I don't know that has to be a
electrical short-circuit and or whatever
so you know there's never really a
scenario where you're ever going to get
logical concrete proof I don't think
because that's not the world with which
you're dealing you're not dealing with
the logic world so who would you guys
want to contact if in fact is there's
ghosts it would be my first phone call
exact if I literally had a ghost a ghost
call you have a backbone up staccato and
oh yeah oh what ghost am I gonna be all
here you wanna contact is it with a
Patou the relative is a question we want
goodness it's anyone I mean that's so
that's literally anybody that's passed
away maybe pass away yeah um I don't
know maybe you got a dead guy you know
Jesus I don't think that is technically
how that last really he's a holy go
that's not how it works you know I'm
gonna have men night I'm gonna say we go
to baby a family member yeah because if
somebody you want you want to say how
are ya yet I've never felt like my money
to Stanford was worth less than this
moment if gambling man hey that's
amazing family America he who are your
go to Jesus and you would have a family
member I talk about needing an education
that's how it works he's not he's not a
ghost like floating around up key the
Holy Ghost even it's very different all
right
well this is my my new one this is this
is the show is that this is the show
yeah it's got a very good clips of it
are people doubtful because you've seen
the other reenactment shows I'm sure you
guys have seen those type of shows yeah
we don't their lies are not generally
not do it I was I know I get it I get it
your shows different yeah but do people
assume it's the same and approach you in
something you're lying to them this
stigma is something we did way better
yeah I mean I assumed going into this is
a good like goddamn it here we go
they're gonna be like
big like what any one of those go shows
were yeah what do you heard something we
went into it but that was really
important for us going into it like I
said it's like we did we weren't going
to do it if the network or whoever was
running and they go they were so
supportive of us the whole time we said
like we just want authenticity it feels
man it doesn't feel like a child like
that it actually feels it's probably I
hope it yes crop yeah because it's a
tough sell ownership because it because
really at the end of the day it isn't a
paranormal show it's an adventure sure
yeah
it's an adventure show with fathers and
sons we end our adventures just happen
to be they don't accept the urban
legends I grew up being obsessed I'm
going to say it was your father into
ghosts is that how where did you get it
the love you know what it is it's from
Scooby Doo little kid it's from Leonard
Nimoy's in search of yeah it's from
unsolved mysteries yeah it's from a
great show by the way mom you guys
missed that one I solve mysteries call
wanting to call it if you've seen them
yeah rich all of that all of that stuff
sort of you know you're I think you're
always formed by what you're entertained
by when you're a kid yeah and and this
is a this is an example of that I'm just
figuring out who's the best looking guy
here Priya where I'm happy to it's a
competition I you got to go to an guys
someone has to win like there's always a
winner and a loser like who's the best
looking I watched your roast so I'm
thinking about what you guys could be up
to as in college and I'm thinking if you
guys have that one of them floral fall
from the tree you both know you're
attractive as well but who is the best
looking here Oh what I think we need to
open the lines for the public for dogs